[Music]
in four days Abby Lee Miller checks into
a federal prison so how is she spending
her last days of freedom I just want to
kind of enjoy some laughter and some fun
I have some friends coming out from
Pittsburgh that have been with me
through thick and thin and for 20 years
before TV show so they're gonna come out
and we're just gonna reminisce and laugh
about the old times we'll be joining in
and talk about everyone we know and who
might have all that money this is not me
who's going with you when you do check
in to present life I believe cameras
will be rolling right why was important
for you to kind of like it let the
cameras come with you it wasn't it
wasn't important to me it was important
to them really yes you regret that
they're showing up you wish you could
fight it
I signed a four-year contract with a
four-year option and you know my
signature is actually on that you look
amazing I mean how is life after her
surgery you uh good you know my eyes and
my brain are definitely still ordering
off a menu like they used to
are you concerned about keeping the
weight off in prison no I'll just mean a
concentrate on and that's different I've
always put everybody else's child first
before my own health so I think this
will be a little me time finally will
you be teaching dance in prison come on
I might be I don't know I don't really
know
[Music]
you